Speaker 1: OK, I want to talk about something
that is unfortunately going to become a trend,
which is people finding ways to get a pseudo
Rie's real, I guess I would call exemption
for either vaccination or mask wearing.
OK, as we see more and more requirements put
in place, even if the requirements are what
we would call like a soft requirement, where
it's like you got to get vaccinated or you
can test weekly.
So you could just test weekly as we are seeing
more and more schools, including in the state
of Florida, say no, no, no to Rhonda Santurce.
Even if you don't want masks in schools, we,
the school board are putting masks on these
kids because they're unvaccinated and we need
to do it.
It just makes sense.
You're going to see more and more shady mechanisms
for people to try to get themselves or their
kids out of wearing a mask or getting a vaccine.
There is a chiropractor offering mask, medical
exemption notes in Florida.
Business Insider has a report.
A Florida chiropractor issued over 500 mask
exemptions for students in Sarasota County.
A chiropractor in Florida.
OK, as I said, district spokesman Craig Amnicola
told the Herald Tribune a third of all medical
exemptions in the district were signed by
chiropractor Dan Busch at Twin Palms Chiropractic.
One guy, one guy.
The county started imposing mask mandates
on students on Monday, defying Florida Gov..
Rhonda Santos's executive order banning Marzook
mandate that last Monday.
This all happened over the last week after
rumors started circulating that Bush was giving
out preassigned medical exception forms.
Sarasota County School Superintendent Brennan
Asplin issued an updated Marzook exemption
form on Tuesday.
Marzook exemptions can now only be issued
by licensed medical doctors, osteopathic physicians
or advanced registered nurse nurse practitioners.
Bush denied accusations that he was giving
out pre signed forms.
I myself will tell you I have not given exemptions
to any parents I have not met with.
That's different.
He also says I'm not an anonymous person or
an anti VAX person, but I'm pro freedom.
Pro choice.
Sarasota's one of 10 school districts in Florida
going ahead with mandates.
Mask mandates against the governor's order
to school districts have had funding withheld,
but are still continuing with the mandate.
Of course, Florida seeing a spike in covid
among children cases among children under
12, up 30 percent the week ending August 26
cases.
Among those, 12 to 19, up 26 percent.
So check this out.
This is video from an event in Florida where
people are lining up in order to get exemptions
from this guy.
People just all lined up working hard to prevent
their kids from having to wear a mask.
This was an event held by this guy.
These are pictures of armed guards at the
event.
Let me see if I can, but now,
Speaker 2: you know, typically
Speaker 1: you wouldn't need armed guards
with what I guess are bulletproof vests or
better know if you call it a flak jacket.
It's looking even a little small and and long
guns.
In camo, I mean, like typically you don't
need that when you're doing something medical
in this way, people saying how could this
possibly be legal?
And one of the things that keeps coming up
is this promo, this event took place yesterday,
mask exemption, a valuation event.
So that's important, right?
You got to you got to call it an evaluation
event Sunday, September 12 at noon, ET 26,
South Moon Road in Venice.
This was yesterday.
And it says parent, guardian and student required
to attend.
So they have to be their medical records helpful,
but not mandatory.
So you can just show up and be like, you know,
my kid's struggles to breathe with the mask
or whatever.
And then I guess the good the good chiropractor
would say, ma'am or sir, your kid qualifies
for this thing.
Now, I wonder if customers have to sign a
sorry, sorry patient customers.
I wonder if the patients of this chiropractor
have to sign a disclaimer so that if the Marcellus
relative or someone that gets the virus from
them dies, they can't then go and sue this
chiropractor.
Is that something that they have to sign and
imagine what is going on in your head where
never mind saying, I think I'm going to find
a mask, opt out for my kid.
I think I'm going to go and stand in line
for maybe hours to get a mask, opt out for
my kid, like what is going on in people's
lives, what is going on in people's heads,
that that is something that they would go
and that they would do.
This sort of reminds me, you know, in the
early days of medical marijuana.
And as a reminder, I believe it should be
recreationally legal and regulated and all
this stuff in the early days of medical marijuana,
there were sort of what you would call like
pro pot doctors where you could just go.
And there have been some investigations on
this about how sort of silly it was.
You go in and you say, I need a medical marijuana
card because my back hurts.
And this would be a doctor you had never seen
before.
And they would have you do a couple of movements
and they would say and tell me where it hurts.
And then they would just kind of like it generically,
say, yeah, here's a prescription for your
marijuana and you get a card and then you
go.
And it was like sort of understood, you know,
you're paying a couple hundred bucks for the
console and it's basically just like a rubber
stamp type thing.
This seems like the same thing.
If the difference being someone just going
and getting medical marijuana when maybe they
should really only be getting recreational
hurts, No one.
And it actually potentially keeps someone
out of the out of dealings with law enforcement
for something that shouldn't be a law enforcement
issue altogether.
All these parents going and opting out their
kids for masks actually has a societal effect
and can actually lead to we see more kids
than at any point in the pandemic in the ICU
and in the hospital for covid, but also then
they bring it home to other people.
It's a mess and it has a huge societal effect.
But the the consult strikes me as some of
what was going on early with the absurdity
of the medical only marijuana, which is a
very different thing.
It's different medically and it's different
societally as well.
This is not boding particularly well for us
exiting the pandemic anytime soon.